oh this is always a lot of fun welcome
back to game on vegas this is the most
fun of the
half hour right we turned back to hands
now las vegas isn't that old but it's
got some great sports history so another
week we open up that sports vault
all right since it's almost time and
unlv has a rich basketball history why
not take a look back at the running
rebels back when they competed on a
national stage were they in the
spotlight
every single week every game and guess
what the running rebels
we were running they were running they
were not jogging they were the running
rebels
mike will do a good job for us there and
greg did a good job for us we're trying
to work it out where
both of them handled the ball and uh and
still we're trying to play real fast so
we haven't changed our break around
totally but
we made some adjustments well you know
we try every day to stress board play i
hope we're going to get better at it
so much of that is just a matter of
concentration because we're big enough
and we can jump well enough
all right there's jerry tarkin of course
the legendary jerry tarkanian
well the mountain west tournament opens